leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu diesem neuen video ich
sitze hier mit luca wer direkt vom
fußball kommt und dementsprechend ist
hungrig bist krank hungrig oder gar
nichts gegessen und du willst du willst
nicht irgendwas essen sondern gewiss
null sterne essen essen besteht ist wenn
man hunger hat dann will man nun schnell
andere gerne essen ihr kennt das bereits
ich habe schon video dazu gemacht es
gibt restaurants wir haben null sterne
und das heißt nicht dass ich schlecht
sind sondern dass sie einfach noch nicht
bewertet worden es ist also quasi wie
eine kleine wundertüte
was wir bekommen und logischerweise
direktor aus ich beim letzten mal hatte
sind mittlerweile alle ausgeflogen es
gibt ganz neue mit 0 sternen deshalb
kommt ist das jetzt mal an kann übrigens
kann man drehen und große schau dort an
die jungs dass sie alles nur damit wir
hier drehen kann ich dafür stellen wir
euch auch also wir filtern natürlich als
erstes mal nach bewertung und dann fängt
schon ein
wir gehen ganz sonntag so wartet schon
vorbei hier schon vorbei wo man sagen
kann wir müssen höher
der laden dann da muss man ganz flott
geben er ist nicht schlecht hält input
experience hat doch stimmlich ich weiß
auch dass wissen ich fahre jeden fall
vorbei wind richtig wild ins büro fahren
wenn ich angehen der wollte h und büro
okay hier ist kein einziges was ein
sterne haben wir zum scheiß tag erwischt
und die sind alle schon bewertet dass
wir die leute ich habe praktisch hat ein
paar biografien komplett in den bach
runtergehen sehen weil ihr seht übrigens
ist kein persönlicher kopf es ist ein
anderes video
wir haben es klug hat eigentlich mein
arsch gerettet muss man so sagen einmal
applaus für luca kein höppner hat hallo
jungs ich erzähle ich glaube dass wir
alle ganz nord lachen ja wisst ihr wie
lange denn viele leben genauso wie kurze
wisst ihr wie lange delfine leben also
wie lange der viele leben aber da sind
zu grillen
dies ergibt die skate weil du hast ja
hat man mir gesagt haben dass das netz
ohne gleichheit der bisher
wer aber von den bisher bestehenden
stellen wir bei zwei restaurants einfach
dass sie sind jetzt leben mit der genau
wie check das alles gibt es katy
halligalli so anscheinend so waffeln
süße zeug mister richie linker war ein
bisschen james kennt man die löhner
decker das hat beim letzten mal
irgendwie werden die bewertung nicht
gespeichert i mate kenne ich auch schon
piazza
das klingt irgendwie interessant
interesse okay was nehme ich würde sagen
auf jeden fall ich will für mich den
cheesecake laden ja und du darfst ja
auch gleich einen auswählen aber wir
gucken jetzt schießt beliebte gerichte
cheesecake box es für 220 euro ihr nehmt
mir einmal berlin
ich habe keine ahnung was jetzt bestelle
weil das dauert wahrscheinlich ewig sich
die hier beschreiben würde dubai dubai
auch genannt
so komisch wenn leute so ihr essen nach
irgendwelchen städten bin ja hier wird
es nun weiter okay wir machen es berlin
dubai new york/tokio ich weiß nicht was
das ist den meisten städten schon für
diese weise new york das war
ich werde jetzt bestellen und die erste
bestellung ist raus und du kannst jetzt
gerne auch null sterne laden raussuchen
lacht schon räumlich traum zumindest
diesen schnupperten halbes hähnchen menü
wir haben das halbe hähnchen halbes
hähnchen wissen straight minister richie
nehmen ich sag gleich dass gewagt
wer nich wat wenn ich falle ihr menü mit
pommes ohne verhalten wenn ich eine
halbe sekunde
freiheit hier zwei arbeiten am 33
wir sehen uns gleich
was haben die für eine soße dabei doch
was ist das so jogo loki bisschen
komisch man kann nichts seine sicht
bisschen wie bisher drei major joghurt
sahne keine ahnung was da auf
bestattungen das gleichzeitig probieren
immer lokal wird kleinigkeiten wird er
niemals macht klar war sehr wild kranz
ist aber nicht da aber man hatten retten
können es geht gar nicht wenn der fahrer
sich so komplett verkehrt einmal angels
gut
richie besten ich habe immer schon
gesagt dass dann hatte ich schwöre
minister richie wenn du das siehst ja
virus ist warum ich mein ich habe nicht
an dich geglaubt sage ich ehrlich ich
nehm ich habe mich war das ein letztes
goodbye gesagt haben bin ich mit dem
gewürz ketchup so grauenvoll so lecker
das ist sehr sehr sehr saftig nicht mit
rösler mithalten
das training gegend wo man in köln seit
und das bild ist der hähnchen essen
wollte rösler 100pro das ist sehr sehr
kraft aber für mitgeliefertes das nicht
diese kabel ein alter also das hähnchen
wir müssen uns überlegen welche
bewertung hat das restaurant verdient 10
05 10 15 für mister ritchie im 914
überhaupt irgendwann ersten viereinhalb
weiß ist vielleicht auch einfach dem
liefern geschuldet ist fehlt so ein
bisschen so der plan schon so war das
eigentliche hähnchen sehr sehr lecker
also viereinhalb bin ich da sehr fein
mit bauen jetzt lass uns noch ein
bisschen was aus sparen vergleich jetzt
probieren wir mal die cheesecake ich
will auch alle dicker aber ich sage okay
ich nehme als erstes maxi king trophy
fairen sagen wir hier ist es ein traum
mit mir videos zu drehen oder man erhält
man ist einfach immer der tat persönlich
hat kopf mich war es für 1 tag haben
sich die carmen steak gemacht
essen wir das mit serie gewürzte job ja
[Musik]
das ist die kleinste version etwa um ein
blog ist das backup das ist so pervers
die krieg mehr geld von ihrem obmann ist
dass man bei summer weißen okay jetzt
kann man noch und jahre zu leben ich
kann davon muss ich noch arbeiten auch
von innen ist ein ganz normales kate ich
glaube ich habe irgendwo ready oder so
habe ich auch schon mal davon gehört
aber ich habe es mir nicht angeschaut
und meinen der grand prix aber jetzt
können wir noch diesen posten jetzt hier
aber moulson bereits länger ich bin ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass es so lecker
wird das hähnchen ist osterkuchen auto
das wird uns sagen hier wird hart
geschuftet
wenn man ganz warm und lebt von
cheesecake wir müssen eigentlich alle
probieren also schauen wir ungefähr weiß
clip stellt für euch probiert noch einig
sagte ehrlich kinder country ist glaube
ich unter den verbleibenden mein favorit
will mit diesen so krank aber ganzes
kinder country dance mix am punkten und
ein snack sitzt sie auf einem stuhl
also ich sage jetzt schon diabetes sagt
er das ist sehr geil und pervers wenn
man das anschaut das ist ehrlich gesagt
aber die summe von sechs kinder country
cheesecake und vertreiber ist nicht
geiler als alles einzeln also ich glaube
dadurch dass alles so zusammen trifft
ist macht nimmt einfach sein händchen
als männer für mich ist das habe ich
einen 4
es muss schlechter sein als hähnchen was
nicht passieren darf man nicht aus
aber was gibt's zu dem ganzen team
cheesecake dem die wirtschaft 55 alter
besser sagt und dem die 155 g j und
fragte er das ist absolut feiert gerade
viel zu süß man ja ok aber es ist
verwerflich sagt wie es ist kinder
achtet auf eure ernährung wir müssen den
menschen mitteilen ob das gute
restaurants sind oder nicht eigentlich
habe der cheesecake laden doch eine zwei
von fünf verdient weil das hier recht
schlau wenn ein restaurant so was mit
dazu packen das nicht ganz einen kurzen
moment packen und mich ab moderieren
so leute danke dass er zugeschaut habt
vier und viereinhalb von 5 wirklich sehr
stabil beides das sei ein bisschen
kleiner aus als es geschmeckt hat aber
immer wieder ein erfolg auf jeden fall
danke dass du dabei warst danke dass ich
essen durfte sagt mir leid dass ich auch
so total tot bin aber wir waren gestern
denken dass sex und jetzt mal wieder
fußball spielen und ich habe auch nicht
bloß kein problem
luca du stehst
philipp schon daraus machen
[Musik]